over the next two days and only on CBS
this morning be sure to watch Nora's
conversation with Priscilla Chan a
doctor philanthropist and wife of
Facebook founder Mark Zuckerberg chan
took us inside an Oklahoma prison where
female inmates are learning how to code
I was just talking to a woman in the
classroom and she's been incarcerated
for 17 years and she is ready to return
to her community and wants to contribute
and she knows that the industry in the
world has moved forward and we need to
be giving people who are incarcerated
the cutting-edge skills chan also opened
up about life with her husband Mark
Zuckerberg and what the future holds for
them do you have political ambitions no
no I don't even want to sit here to talk
to you
I've does Mark have political ambitions
no no for our family Chad also talked
about the Chan Zuckerberg initiative one
of the most well funded philanthropic
organizations in the world and its plan
to cure all diseases by the end of the
century the first part of our report
airs tomorrow only on CBS this morning
lover honesty though yeah